good morning everybody it is seven
o'clock you're very welcome to join us
on the breakfast show here on sky news
this monday morning another day
another warning over the state of the
nhs and how a staffing crisis could put
patients at risk how would the two
people find to be the next pm deal with
it as the war of words between liz trust
and rishi sunak turns to china we'll be
joined by members of the two teams camps
on today's programme the education
secretary that's james cleverly of
course from team tross and the former
health secretary jeremy hunt from team
sunac and what's happening at our ports
with bumper to bump accused for
holidaymakers and hawleys alike is
brexit to blame we'll get the view of
the shadow chancellor rachel reeves and
we'll analyze what the polls are saying
in our new feature the daily polling pit
stop with the pollster joe twyman it is
monday the 25th of july
war of words over china as the fighting
between the two tories battling for the
keys to number 10
steps up another gear
a warning patient's safety is at risk in
the worst ever staffing crisis for the
nhs
silence was speaking out the faces of
the pro-democracy activists put to death
in myanmar the first executions since
1988.
firefighters remained here overnight as
fears that a large blaze on hinkley
common could reignite and people have
been urged to stay away
and we'll hear warnings to stay safe in
the water as an increasing number of
people drown while swimming in the uk
no bot the moment a robot went rogue
during a chess game and broke a
seven-year-old's finger
as more summer holidays are blighted by
backlogs we'll speak to a travel expert
on where you can go in the uk if you
want to avoid the headache
also coming up on the program for you
this morning wherever you're watching us
around the world a lifeline for female
same-sex couples as red tape to nhs
funded ivf treatment is removed i'll
speak to two women who've campaigned for
fertility equality while spending
thousands on private treatment
and the pooches catching the perfect
ride we'll dive into the annual dog
surfing championships speaking to the
festival's organizer alongside a
semi-finalist that's coco the canine
[Music]
hi everyone a very good morning to you
an nhs staffing crisis putting patients
at risk a war of words with france over
endless tailbacks at the port of dover
are now a war of words over china
whoever becomes the next prime minister
has got a lot in their inbox and liz
tross and rishi sunuk are fighting to
take it on the latest in fighting is
over china the former chancellor saying
it poses the biggest long-term threat to
britain the trust camp saying this kind
of talk is surprising given how the
treasury wanted to do an economic deal
with china given all of that what are
the polls saying time now for our new
feature it's the daily polling pit stop
to analyze what they're suggesting
george wyman's uh with us i can tell you
like the alliteration from delta poll of
course it's great to see you thanks for
joining us where are we with the polls
well it was an interesting uh an
interesting weekend because we had polls
coming out of conservative party members
of course this crucial group that will
elect the new prime minister and the
general public
both the public generally and also
conservative supporters and it was quite
a mixed bag in terms of in terms of
conservative party members
we saw that liz trust was actually
growing her lead over rishi sunak and so
she's over over 60 percent now which is
a which is a strong lead but actually in
line with performances in previous uh
conservative membership contests where
the winners tend to win by some distance
so it's looking good for her in that
respect
but in terms of the general public the
situation was more interesting at delta
poll we ran a voting intention question
that showed that that showed that the
labour party were 11 points ahead uh but
when you ran hypothetical questions
asking what if let's trust the leader
what if was she soon aqua leader we saw
the situation didn't change very much
okay and if you're 60
you know 40 ahead or however you do the
math you're much better at these figures
than me at this stage of the race
doesn't necessarily mean you're going to
win definitely not and what we saw
across all of the polls was high levels
of don't knows on some of the questions
for instance who would be best on the
economy you do get uh you do get strong
feelings in this case towards rishi
sunak for the general public
but you still have large numbers of
people sometimes 40 50 percent of people
saying they don't know and that's true
for the general public but it's also
true for conservative supporters
conservative voters and conservative
members and so with
so many weeks still remaining anything
could still happen because the polls are
only ever a snapshot of where we are at
the moment and both these candidates are
firstly relatively unknown still and
that's true among the general public and
true among conservative members but
they're also relatively untested and so
we've seen them now in two but not three
debates we have another debate tonight
and the following one tomorrow so this
is your um latest delta poll talk us
through it oh well uh this was the
question about who would be the uh who
would be the best prime minister and it
highlights really the problem that the
conservative face because this is uh
this is among conservative voters from
the last election so that group the
conservatives really need to hold on to
and we found that a plurality of them
across all of the different conservative
groups thought that it was right a good
thing that boris johnson resigned and
yet when given the choice between all
three candidates it was boris johnson
who was the favorite so yes they think
it was right that he leaves but they're
not convinced by his replacement and
again it illustrates that the
conservatives have some way to go and
just on that before we have a look at
the yougov poll where you used to work
of course and 97 of 2019 tory voters
valued honesty in a leader now
that chap has been sacked twice for
lying and that's why he's lost his job
probably a third time uh yes that but
before he got the job last time 97 of
them valid honestly as well and so it
goes to show that uh that people can
value these things but are sometimes
willing to compromise on their uh uh
compromise on their ideals to get what
they want in other words okay so they
think he's got the best chance of
beating labour at the next election yes
that's what they're saying let's have a
look at the yougov poll as well if we
may
here we go um 56 value being able to win
the next general election as a top
priority so that's again playing into
what your poll is saying yes and second
behind uh behind winning the next
election which is of course all
important to conservative party members
was control of immigration and we saw on
the in the headlines in this morning's
newspapers how both the candidates going
very hard on that and of course they
will be doing their own polling of
members and of conservative voters as
well and so they'll know what their top
priorities are and it's no surprise to
me that that's then reflected in the
headlines and how will the polling pit
stop change depending on the hustings
and the tv debates tv debates such as
they're all important tv debates tv
debates have the potential they always
have the potential to make a difference
but after the uh shall we say rather
aggressive approach the uh certainly
these two candidates took to the
previous debates it will be interesting
to see whether they go for a more
conciliatory approach with the two
debates that are upcoming i don't
imagine they'll have an immediate impact
on the on the polling but what they may
do is put a marker down that the other
can constantly refer back to and that
cumulative effect could make a
difference and voters care about tv
debates because
because it's a chance to see these
candidates really in many cases for the
first time
many people don't know who liz trust is
many people might have heard of rishi
sunak they're really not familiar with
any of his policies or ideas so they
provide an opportunity and in many cases
the first opportunity to get themselves
in front of uh in front of these people
in summary
she's way ahead at the moment but
nothing to be taken for granted in
summary it's liz trusses to lose but
there is so much uh so much time left
and so many people who are undecided
that it's very much all to play for okay
it's great to see you thanks very much
youtube for coming in thank you that's
our purlin pit stop for you this morning
we'll have another one tomorrow to
reflect on how the polls are looking
what are the papers saying well the eye
reports the tory leadership race is
turning toxic ahead of the first live tv
debate between the two final contenders
that's this evening
the telegraph leads on rishi sunak's
accusation that liz tross was soft on
china's influence on british
universities while she was an education
minister
but the daily mail says liz trust has
herself called mr sunak's get tough
stance on china into question
and the daily express also goes with the
race to number 10 as liz trust says her
tax breaks will boost britain
tamara's here uh for her latest
reflection now hi tomorrow uh reflection
on what's happened over the weekend hi
kate well it was richie sunak and liz
truss's clashes in the previous debates
which really stood out and we've had
plenty more of them over the weekend in
several different areas migration both
of them wanted to be the toughest on
illegal migration and build on the
rwanda policy on china both accusing the
other of having been too soft on china
and of course on tax and we may see more
of that in the first head-to-head debate
on the bbc tonight but they may well
also be asked about issues like the nhs
workforce crisis that we heard about
today and of course the difficulties at
ports along the south coast and how much
of that is to do with brexit so we'll
see whether they are clashing whether
they're trying to be more conciliatory
what brick bats what banana skins do
they need to watch out for i think
there'll be lots of discussion about the
economy and that's going to be a key one
for many tory members who of course are
making their decisions from next week
okay tomorrow we'll see you a little bit
later on when we had an opportunity to
speak to some of the ministers thank you
and a reminder that rishi sunak and liz
trust will go head to head in a live
televised debate here
on sky news when is it i can hear you
shouting at the telly well it's a week
on thursday that's the 4th of august and
that's at 8 00 pm here on sky news if
you would like to be a member of the
live studio audience and can be in with
a chance of asking a question please
apply via the link on the sky news app
and also the sky news website
coming up in today's program for you
we'll hear from both camps in the
leadership race the chair of the health
and social care committee and rishi soon
as supporter that's jeremy hunt will be
with me very shortly and the education
secretary and liz trust supporter that's
james cleverley will be with me just
after eight o'clock
meantime labour's setting up their plan
to reboot the economy today you'll get
the latest with the shadow chancellor
that's rachel reeves
[Music]
meantime the military government of
myanmar has executed four political
opponents in the country's first use of
capital punishment since 1982
were democracy activists convicted under
the country's counter-terrorism law
let's find out more should we our asia
correspondent tom cheshire standing by
tom good morning terrible news coming
out of myanmar this morning
morning yeah this is a really grim
development i think it's one that makes
the prospect of any end to the conflict
the civil war in myanmar uh much further
away we have of course seen
extrajudicial killings in myanmar rights
group estimate that more than 2 000
people have been killed but this is
different this is the state executing uh
these four activists as you say for the
first time in decades they say they're
accused of terror acts and this is all
according to justice but the opposition
see this as a means of trying to
intimidate the population to silence
them uh with fear and this is part of
increasing you know ruthlessness from
the military uh in myanmar in terms of
holding on to their power we've seen
that ever since the protests uh which
started as a result of them seizing
power in february last year there were
peaceful protests they were dispersed
those extrajudicial killings we've also
seen them detain lots of democracy
activists including aung sang
who if she's convicted of all the crimes
she faces and faces the sentence would
be behind bars for more than a hundred
years so this is you know a sign really
of how desperate the military is to keep
its power and what's notable about this
is that they had been warned by the
international community the un secretary
general antonio gutierrez condemned the
death sentence when it was announced and
he said it shouldn't go ahead the prime
minister of cambodia has been leading
the response of the southeast asian
nations around this warned them not to
do it they didn't think it would be good
for the stability of the region but
still they have pressed ahead there has
been condemnation already from the
united nations special reporter who said
this was in violation of international
human rights law and must be a turning
point for the international community we
haven't seen that turning point yet we
will see what action the international
community takes but the military
determined not to pay heat to any of the
warnings they had before these
executions okay thank you
several large wildfires broke out around
london and the southeast yesterday
including one in surrey which was
declared a major incident firefighters
continued to monitor the situation
overnight at hankley common and people
are still being advised to avoid the
area let's find out more should we sadia
is standing by for us at the common hi
saria tell us more
well at least eight hectares of land
have been affected by this fire but as
you can see it has been
taken and under control there's just a
few wisps of smoke this morning but
firefighters did remain here overnight
they'd been called around at midday
yesterday and several fire trucks were
involved in this and they remained
overnight as a precaution just because
there were fears that
new fires could reignite from that large
blaze that we saw yesterday
now a lot a major incident was declared
yesterday but that has been downgraded
but despite that people are being urged
not to come into this area there are
signs as you're driving around here
urging the public to avoid this area but
also to take precautions uh to avoid
fires like this in the first place
especially in this heat so things like
not throwing away litter in any old
place not throwing away cigarettes but
also crucially not to have barbecues
because in hot weather like this they
don't just start fires really quickly
but that can also cause it to spread
very fast too
okay thank you thanks very much
now a destructive wildfire near yosemite
national park was burning out of control
last night and grew into one of
california's biggest blazes of the year
so far thousands of residents were
ordered to flee remote mountain
communities some 2 000 firefighters are
battling the oak fire contending with
steep terrain and also hot weather
as growing numbers of people lose their
lives in british waterways a new
drowning awareness campaign is being
launched to mark world drowning
prevention day which is today um the
world health organization puts drowning
among the 10 leading causes of death in
the in children worldwide here in
britain at least 14 accidental drownings
have been reported this month alone amid
that record-breaking heat wave
terrible isn't it last year 277 people
died in accidental drownings in the uk
that's an increase from 254 people in
2020.
the royal life-saving society believes
the risk of staycations is partly to
blame
the predominant factor for that is we
believe more people are staying at home
they're obviously migrating to the coast
to inland waters when it gets hot
and unfortunately that
in in some instances is resulting in
tragedies accidental drownings uh can be
avoided it just takes a little bit of
knowledge
about water safety linked to swimming
well becky's at sulphur keys where two
young lads have sadly lost their lives
already this month hi uh becky and we
were speaking actually to the greater
manchester mayor who says they're aware
of the challenges and they they are
warning young people to stay away from
open water sadly to now having lost
their lives in in the keys just behind
you
yeah just over a week ago 16 year old
kaelin moore sadly died here at salford
keys and the problem is that it can feel
very hot not today but certainly last
week but if the water is 15 degrees
celsius or below it can cause the body
to go into cold water shock which can be
fatal and the concern is obviously we
are at the start of the school holidays
that more kids will be out and might be
tempted to get into the water and might
get into trouble and actually the
majority of drownings in the uk happen
at inland open bodies of water like this
or reservoirs or canals or lakes
and the advice is if you do go swimming
do it somewhere where there is
supervision like a lifeguard but if you
do get into trouble to float on your
back and if you see someone drowning
obviously call 999 and if there is
something you can throw which floats
like this emergency throw line to throw
that into the water
um okay and what what advice are we
hearing for parents i mean
these kids are 15 16 17 aren't they it's
difficult to know where they are all the
time they just need to be aware of this
water don't they need to be aware that
it's
even if they think they're very strong
swimmers
jump in that cold water can mean that
you take so much water into your lungs
yeah and that's the thing i think the
statistic is 60 of people who drown can
actually swim but they just don't
anticipate how cold the water will be
and the advice is you say obviously kids
do want to get into the water and have
fun with their friends if there isn't a
lifeguard somewhere like this to get
into the water slowly so there is less
chance your body will go into cold water
shock
okay for now thank you thanks very much
british man feared to have drowned in
lake garda after diving in to save his
teenage son the man named as aaron
chadder hired a boat with his two
children and partner on the italian
naked near limoni on friday
they were about 500 metres from the
shore when mr chad's 14 year old son got
into trouble in the water mr chatter is
said to have dived in and saved his son
but slipped under the water
and has not been seen since the coast
guard has launched a large rescue effort
but they believe the 51 year old who's
from leicestershire might have had a
seizure from the shock of the cold water
and drowned
please be careful around water it looks
so inviting when it's hot it really
could take your life if you've got
youngsters keep them well away unless
they're supervised and aware of how cold
that water is it might be very warm you
know we've had the hottest days ever in
the uk the water is still cold it's a
very cold 16 degrees that's going to put
your body into shock you ingest the
water in your lungs and that's it
let's look at some of today's other
headlines for you now
our father and mother as well as their
six-year-old daughter were fatally shot
while camping at an iowa state park
authorities says the suspected gunman
he's a 23 year old named as anthony
sherwin was found dead in a wooded area
of the park the family's nine-year-old
son survived the attack and is safe
a gofundme page has been set up to try
to provide the sun with more financial
stability for the future
new figures suggest that two in five
airport workers are considering leaving
the industry
a survey of seventeen hundred workers by
jobsite cv library found some of the
main reasons included wanting better pay
and less stress
while five percent blame the current
situation at uk airports
pope francis has arrived in canada on a
week-long visit to apologize to
indigenous people for abuses committed
by catholic missionaries at residential
schools
indigenous groups are pressing for
access to archives in an attempt to
uncover the fate of children who never
returned home from the schools
a volcano on japan's main southern
ireland has erupted sending rocks and
ash more than a mile and a half away
the eruption alert from sakurajima
volcano has been raised to the highest
level of five prompting the evacuation
of a number of residential areas but
authorities say they don't expect a
large scale eruption
quick look at our weather for you know
warm memories wherever you go
[Music]
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
high pressure building in the west will
bring more settle conditions over the
next few days although a few showers are
likely the northwesterly flow will bring
lower temperatures and more comfortable
conditions
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
more comfortable conditions who couldn't
say that this time last week could we
the highest ever recorded temperature
here in the united kingdom and remember
there was the fires uh wildfires as a
result
of that particularly in the area of
wennington's remember the sort of
problems that would cause that whole row
of houses gone well as the fires
continued over the weekend the threat to
homes and communities was being laid
bare in wellington that bore the brunt
of those fires last week is iva bennett
it looks more like a war zone than a
village in greater london but this is
what climate change can do tuesday's
fires gutted at least 17 houses here
leaving empty shells and piles of rubble
this one was my mum's culture
that one was my dad's a sad note
george's parents had lived here for more
than 50 years and it's here where the
fire started they weren't in at the time
because his elderly father's in hospital
but had they been he's certain they'd be
gone as well
they wouldn't about run it my dad would
have been trying to put their eyes up
with a half inch guard nose and my mum
right behind him saying would you want
me to throw this bowl of
water now they're gonna run that up
eight years you ain't
it runs it can go faster than me and you
can run
so they wouldn't have got they wouldn't
have gone out
george's family didn't tell his dad what
happened for three days afraid the news
would be too much a lifetime of
possessions obliterated memories are now
all they have left
i mean there's all sorts of silly things
here like my old nan's last packet of
[ __ ] she
had four she gave up smoking 30 years
ago and
and i just want to get in there and
there must be something in there they
must be saying i'll give them back there
must be
just one thing you know
you always knew
the door was open sort of thing there it
ain't
as the fire took cold other houses were
at the mercy of the wind the gusts
sending flames seemingly in random
directions sparing some properties but
wiping out others
these houses are actually quite far from
where the fire started and they're the
only ones on this block that got
destroyed but that's because the fire
came from behind the houses it was swept
this way across the fields and gardens
behind and it didn't stop here it was so
hot that it effectively jumped across
the road
setting fire to this side of the road
and then from here the flames were swept
very quickly across this field to the
buildings beyond in some places the fire
even caused what's called spalling where
bricks crack under intense heat those
who battled it fear it's important of
what's to come
you know you think oh you know we don't
we don't get how those things don't
happen to us
but all of a sudden now you're looking
at you know looking across the uh
that this scene you're thinking wow you
know
the web our summers are getting hotter
could it happen again
of course it was happened once so yeah
yeah definitely it's understood some
residents whose homes were destroyed are
away on holiday and so are yet to see
what they have left as for george's
parents he says they're unlikely to ever
return to better remember what they once
had
i hope they don't
i wouldn't like them to see it like this
i'd give you your best to keep the
memories you got aren't you
a situation others could face in the
future as our planet continues to heat
up
iva bennett sky news in wennington
greater london
oh my goodness me those poor people can
you imagine just thinking it's a bit hot
today and then totally losing absolutely
everything
that they own we'll keep an eye on
what's happening in uh wellington and
update you as when uh we can meantime
this is a pretty shocking story actually
this morning chess said to be a game of
calm concentration strategic thinking
and patient behavior have a look at this
i know right
in a russian chess federation tournament
a playing robot went rogue apparently
unsettled by the quick responses of a
seven-year-old boy
he grabbed
or it grabbed and broke his finger
during the match at the moscow open the
president of the moscow chess federation
said the robot suppliers were
going to have to think again do you
think
poor chap
he's not going to be his mate is he
here in the guardian we can see that
it's not just who are having to cope not
just us i should say who are having to
cope with the hot weather this group of
deer in london's richmond park opted to
cool off
in the river great picture locals have
been urged to put out water in their
gardens to help the animals out
over the summer lily putting these
pictures together for us today but the
put the petal to the metal that's the
phrase isn't it this photograph from the
telegraph captures children racing at
the goodwood motor circuit in west
sussex
it's the goodwood revival it's the
world's greatest historic motor racing
event
it gets together car enthusiasts and
pass racing champions to celebrate the
sport and they look like they're having
a whale of a time don't they good for
them
and the socialite tamara eccleston
features on page four of the daily
mirror she's offering an eye watering
six
million pound reward for information to
recover her stolen belongings cash
jewelry and gems worth around 25 million
pounds were taken from her kensington
mansion in december of 2019 in what was
britain's biggest ever burglary so far
she has only managed to recover a single
pair
of earrings
the chair of the health and social care
committee and rishi sunax supporter
jeremy hunt will be with us a little bit
later on this hour do stay tuned for
more on that
[Music]
again everybody you're very welcome to
join us on the breakfast show here on
sky news this monday morning tory
leadership hopefuls rishi sunak and liz
trusts trade blows over their approach
to china attacking each other's records
while each promising to take a hard line
mps warned that the nhs is facing its
toughest ever staffing crisis and that
patient safety is being put at serious
risk
myanmar has executed four political
detainees the first use of capital
punishment in decades
[Music]
and as we've been reporting a
cross-party group of mps has said the
nhs is now facing the greatest workforce
crisis in its history putting patient
safety at risk
joining us now is the president of the
royal college of surgeons of england
that's professor neil mortensen hello to
you professor thank you so much for
taking the time to join us on the
programme this morning just how bad is
it
good morning kay um it's pretty bad part
of the problem i guess is
number one we're recovering from the
pandemic so uh there are still
lots of staff who have omicron
so that's having an effect on the
workforce
and then there are large numbers of
vacancies as the report points out
um there are vacancies across all
specialties i'm speaking as a surgeon
but across all specialties medicine
radiology
general practice all the other
specialties
there are
vacancies
and these vacancies of course if you're
part of the workforce are very
undermining if you don't have enough
staff everybody else has to work harder
to fill the gaps and this constant
process of
coping with omicron
and coping with those
staff vacancies makes life extremely
difficult indeed
as far as rishi sunak is concerned he
who would be the next prime minister is
suggesting um that one of the ways
forward is private health care to offset
staff
shortages in other words to move
patients into the private health care
system is that a good idea
well there is some capacity in the
independent sector but uh of course
there are a large number of patients now
that you'll have heard last week
beginning to self-pay
and if they self-pay they use up the
available slots in the independent
sector which has a limited uh number of
gaps and opportunities
and therefore it's more difficult for
the nhs to buy those slots to help
with the backlog and of course um many
of the staff who work in the independent
sector will also be working in the nhs
so there are still a finite number of
staff so
this report which we really welcome
points out the real number of the matter
it's all about workforce workforce
workforce without the pairs of hands we
can't do the job properly
without that 12 billion pounds a year
that we're all having to contribute
towards uh with the increase in national
insurance that came in to play uh last
april would that have um a more
detrimental effect
i bring that up of course because that's
what liz tross would introduce the first
day of her if she was prime minister
um i'm not sure in terms of individual
pay and whether it makes a difference i
i'm sure it makes a big difference
particularly in the social care sector
as you'll have heard we have large
numbers of patients in hospital fit for
discharge but they don't have anywhere
to go
uh i think there is a huge workforce
crisis in social care too
uh there is this blocking of beds by
patients who could go into social care
but of course social care has a massive
problem in terms of workforce too uh and
that will have a knock-on effect on what
happens in hospitals okay professor it's
good to talk to you thank you very much
indeed for joining us thank you well one
registered nurse and gmb union officer
told sky news the issues in the health
service are long-standing
i worked in the nhs for about 15 years
and there's been staffing shortages for
that entire time um there's always a
shortage of qualified nurses there's
always shifts being put out to agency to
try and fill them
the chair of the health and social care
committee jeremy hunt former health
secretary of course so let's just get
that out of the way to start with mr
hunt good morning to you and been a
problem for 15 years um says the nurse
which i mean to what extent do you
accept some responsibility for that
given that you were previously health
secretary
well of course i have to accept some
responsibility but i did set up six new
medical schools
and increase the number of doctors we
train by 25
the problem is because it takes seven
years to train a doctor we won't get any
of those additional doctors through
until 2024
and this is really the point we're
making in our report that we need to
have a system that's much more robust
that doesn't depend on individual health
secretaries or chancellors taking
decisions but gives the nhs confidence
that whoever the government is whoever
the health sector is we will always be
training enough doctors and nurses for
the future and at the moment we think
we're about 12 000 hospital doctors
short about 50 000 nurses short and that
is creating massive pressure on
frontline staff and we are very
frustrated in the committee that despite
having talked about this now for a
couple of years we still don't have a
proper nhs workforce plan in place nor
do we have one in place for the social
care sector as you were just talking
about with professor mortensen
yeah um how close do you think the
government is going to be to recruiting
the
6000 gps that it promised in the
manifesto
well it's it's not easy recruiting extra
gps but since they made that promise in
the 2019 manifesto which i obviously
stood on as a conservative as well uh
we've gone down by about 700 gps
a year ago we said we needed 2 000 more
midwives we've gone down 500 midwives
and i think people in the nhs know
there's no silver bullet they know it
takes three years to train a midwife
seven years to train a doctor 10 years
to train a gp
there's no easy solutions but what they
want is a really solid plan in place so
that you know young people entering the
profession today can at least have some
hope that the pressure isn't always
going to be like it is today
you've been warning i know about the
crisis the workforce crisis for a long
time we've spoken about it often on this
program um you are backing rishi sunak
um who didn't
i think i'm right insane you'll correct
me um who didn't vote for your amendment
in parliament to produce a workforce
plan and he's not really said that much
so far about the workforce when it comes
to talking about the nhs either in
hustings or on tv debates does he get it
well i think i do give him credit that
of the two candidates he's the first
who's actually spoken about the nhs and
he's he's used the word emergency and i
think that's very important because
that's what it feels like on the front
line at the moment that's what it feels
like i think for some of the people who
are waiting for their nhs care
um but the reason i'm supporting is
because the reason i'm a conservative is
because i think only conservative
governments take the tough and difficult
long-term decisions that the country
needs and he was prepared to say
publicly that we can't afford unfunded
tax cuts and i thought that was very
brave and i want someone who who leads
us who tells us things that we don't
always want to hear that's what i think
we should have from a prime minister and
i hope we would have that when it comes
to some difficult decisions respecting
the nhs as well yeah you said a crisis
is referred to as a crisis is also
talked about as having to be on a wall
for footing to deal with it but to to
fight a war you need to have troops
don't you and as you said it's taking a
while for those troops to come along to
the front line should we be looking
overseas to bring in reinforcements
yes there's lots of things we can do in
the short term in the long run of course
we should be training all the doctors
and nurses we need we are one of the
biggest health care systems in the world
um but you know in the short term if
you've got a doctor coming from a
country like germany
or canada why on earth do they need to
go through endless uh checks as to their
medical qualifications when we know
they're coming from a system where
there's very good medical training so we
could definitely speed things up when it
comes to relieving the pressure in the
short term
you did talk he promised
certainly part of a government that
promised um a net migration target i
think under david cameron wasn't it it
didn't happen uh why is rishi sunak
appears to be doing the same thing with
his proposed asylum cap is that what
he's doing
i think it's slightly different i think
what he's saying is that um in a world
where
people are much much more mobile than
they've ever been we've got to recognize
that there needs to be different
structures if we're going to fulfill our
humanitarian responsibilities and we
need to pay our bit other countries need
to pay their bit
and
so we need to be honest about the fact
that there's a limited amount that any
one country can do
but at the same time staying true to
britain's historical generosity to
people in difficulty coming from other
countries
how humane is it to send vulnerable
people to rwanda though
well i think the world has changed and
we used to be in a world where it was
relatively difficult to go across
continents across oceans to get to the
uk so for people who came here would
claim asylum
when they got here but now that process
has become much easier
and if we don't find a different way of
helping them which doesn't encourage the
people smugglers then we are just going
to nurture a really horrible industry
that treats those people really badly so
what we need i think is to have much
better safe legal routes for people to
get here but clamp down on the people
smugglers the people who are trafficking
trafficking people in small boats across
the channel
and all the evils that that involves
completely understood but we did have a
human rights barrister on the programme
just last week and he was saying that he
would be surprised if even one person
was sent to rwanda because every time
the government tries to do that they
will face a legal challenge and they
will lose in the courts
yes and that's why i think it's very
difficult to get this right but i think
the truth is that the status quo is not
sustainable and what we're in what we're
risking at the moment is uh building up
a massive people smuggling industry
and that cannot be the right way to help
people who are vulnerable so what we
need is better safe legal routes to help
people in refugee camps on the border of
syria or coming out of afghanistan help
them get here safely legally
discharge our responsibilities to be a
compassionate humane country but not
nurture this this horrible people
smuggling business
what about the suggestion of floating
asylum centers uh which has been uh
suggested by your candidate is that a
good idea
we're getting quite a long way away from
my health and social care committee
report yeah but you're you know you are
you know you have previously been
foreign secretary and uh
as i know from having spoken to you
previously you can turn your hand to
anything
well that's very generous of you to say
so but um i mean
the truth is we have to be radical we
have to do things differently um and we
have to be courageous and
rishi sunak to me has shown that he's
willing to be courageous in particular
uh being out front to conservative party
members of whom i'm one who all
to a person want tax cuts and say that
say that's not possible at the moment we
can't afford that right now
and i think that's the kind of courage
uh that has persuaded me that he's the
right man to be prime minister but the
same courage and decisiveness is
necessary yes when it comes to asylum
policy refugee policy as well
yeah i mean if you're going to move into
the foreign secretary role again
obviously these are the sort of
questions that people will want to know
the answers to when your man wins or
doesn't he's losing at the moment isn't
he
well um i think there's all to play for
at this stage um in the previous
leadership campaign i was uh a long way
behind boris johnson but i think the
difference between this time and last
time is that then because of brexit a
lot of conservative party members have
firmly made up their minds this time the
poll shows that a lot of people are
still making up their minds they haven't
made their final decision maybe they
wanted some of the other candidates in
the race who are not now part of the
race and so i think there's all to play
for
ten thousand tory voters want boris
johnson back
yes but that may be true i haven't seen
that exact number but there are 175 000
members and you know a decision has been
taken and we do now need to move forward
and i think we've got two excellent
candidates uh both very experienced in
government uh both done their cabinet
jobs extremely well and so i think it's
a very good choice for the conservative
party membership to have and what is it
about rishi sunak and the national
health service that makes you think that
he is a better person to try to
steer us away from up to 14 million
people on the waiting list by the time
of the next general election
well his main involvement as chancellor
has been to make sure that the nhs gets
the funding that it needs and he did
that through the extra 12 billion pounds
a year through the health and social
care levy which again was a a very
difficult decision to take
but what what we're arguing in this
report what i hope you would understand
as prime minister is that it's not just
about money you can put 12 billion a
year or 10 billion a year as it actually
will end up being into the nhs but if
you haven't got to 10 billion bids worth
of extra doctors and nurses if you
haven't got the capacity in the system
you won't get the extra operations that
you need and so that's what we're saying
needs to happen now a very thorough
workforce plan that answers a very
simple question that's on the minds of
of every doctor and nurse
in the nhs how many extra doctors and
nurses are we going to need in the next
five years and 10 years
and do we have a plan in place to
recruit them
just before i let you go this is not
about the health service but it's
something that you know an awful lot
about i'm sure um given um your good
lady at home confucius institutes are
something that we're hearing quite a lot
about um moving on to china of course
they are something that are based in our
um
in our universities here what are they
and why are we so worried about them
well um they were set up with funding
from the chinese government in
universities in this country and indeed
around the world
to promote chinese culture chinese
language
but unfortunately they've also been used
to further
chinese state aims and pushing the
objectives of the chinese communist
party in a way that i think is very
inconsistent with academic freedom so i
think rishi sunak is right to call that
out this morning and say that you know
our universities need to be welcoming to
students from all over the world
including of course china but they need
to be places where academic freedom is
totally respect there's full freedom of
speech people who want to
say things that may upset the regime in
china are completely free to do so um
and kay you've said one last thing to me
i want to say one last thing to you i'm
very sorry that the last time we met i
nearly knocked you over on my bicycle
here is my very public apology for that
in front of all the sky viewers this
morning
i think you might have tried to do it on
purpose but i'll let you i'm sure you
didn't it's great to see you thank you
very much indeed for joining us this
morning mr hunt thank you you did
actually really we're getting a full
story about that yeah yeah
safe to say i was on the pavement is all
i'm saying
serious near mister um
jeremy hunt is obviously chair of the
health select committee and has been
warning since he's very long stint as
health secretary that the nhs his
biggest problem is workforce the
workforce is in crisis you can't get
through the backlog you can't set up
nightingale centers or anything else
without more doctors and more nurses and
this report lays out in very stark terms
the nhs might right now be short of 12
000 hospital doctors and 50 000 nurses
and midwives not to mention the huge
staffing crisis in social care which has
knock-on effect jeremy hunt says that
rishi sunat gets it he knows it's an
emergency he hopes he would devise a
workforce plan but doesn't sound any
stronger than hopes that that would be
the case but he says that he's putting
the funding behind it by keeping that
controversial and difficult national
insurance rise which liz trust has said
that if she became prime minister she
would scrap
who's responsible for this is it the
government that's been in power for 12
years so well the report by the health
select committee chaired by jeremy hunt
says the government has no credible plan
to address it they're doing all right on
recruiting the 50 000 new nurses that
boris johnson talked a lot about doing
badly on doctors and it says that they
need to do things like make
making doctors coming from abroad find
it easier to get work in the nhs
bringing back the nurse bursaries a lot
of things that the conservative
government have done it's now calling on
them to reverse so this may be a big
issue for trust and sunac when they go
in their first head-to-head debate
tonight and of course our debate next
week the nhs and its backlog is one of
voters top concerns okay um coming up uh
you're going to tell me the connection
between liz tross and the boss we'll
save that for the next hour indeed
thanks very much indeed thank you
now over the weekend people were forced
to queue for hours at dover and
folkstone as they attempt to get away
for summer it comes after months of
disruption and delays at airports across
the country
joining us to give her her tips on how
to avoid all the chaos is the travel
expert of course claire elvin hi claire
it's good to see you this morning thanks
for joining us so
what are your top tips either on having
to deal with cueing or for staying uh at
home
well um for dealing with queuing um my
tips on always taking snacks and
travelling so you're traveling with a
toddler isn't going to help massively if
you're stuck in a car in searing heat
for 21 hours so
um all i can wish is anyone doing that
good luck and just do make sure you've
got snacks and water with you um but you
know there are um lots of other
opportunities um the uk of course is uh
you know a really we're very lucky that
we live in the uk in terms of holidays
huge variation in um in landscape and
things to do in places to go
um prices we're seeing falling
after those huge price hikes we saw
after the um the pandemic so
you know it could be a more
affordable option than it was looking um
a few months and even weeks ago
um and of course you know this glorious
weather helps uh not massively
demonstrated behind me at the moment but
you know it's um we're just really lucky
there's you know there are um vineyards
and
huge open spaces go walking great
swathes of um uncluttered coastline and
think about camathonshire for example
which is called the cinderella of the uk
because it's constantly overlooked
uh in favor of pembrokeshire you know
you don't have to head to devon and
cornwall
um and so you know so the uk
loads and loads of
options there or of course you could
look
off season um overseas and um
you know and
take a punt take a risk but you know
you're less likely to get caught up in
travel delays if you do so
interesting you're saying martha and
she'll not call me we've been looking at
that um
uh dumb freeson galloway looking at
dumfries there um instead of devon and
interestingly you say bradford not bath
how does that work
well
i mean bath of course is a really
stunning city and it's a very filmic
city it's been used um you know for many
tv shows and movies but actually
bradford can offer you know its own it
has amazing victorian gothic
architecture yes really
and of course you know and
you could
in front of the town hall for example
you could well imagine that you were on
a scene in bridgeton so
not just stunning architecture but great
curries as well and so you know what
what's not to love there
okay but talk to me about why you know
it looks amazing i love the uk i love
holidaying in the uk but why would you
holiday in the uk instead of somewhere
like southern europe especially uh once
the weather starts to get a little bit
like it is behind you this morning
well you know it's still warm but um
a lot of the delays that we've seen this
weekend are people going to france
france is one of the uk's favorite um
getaways
and in an actual fact the uk can offer a
lot of what france has to offer so for
example
some
monster michelle in normandy you could
head down to michael's mount um
in cornwall yes cornwall is a hot spot
but of course michael's mount um very
beautiful really historic amazing
incredible garden so if you've ever
crossed over um onto the um to the
island and seeing those gardens kind of
teetering in in really um extreme
conditions there really beautiful
um
of course sussex and that's um
obviously at night really beautiful um
dark sky and situation
you could
um
closer to london and maybe some more
transport links you could head to sussex
um which have vineyards to rival those
um
in in france and in champaign um the
the the soil in sussex is said to be
closest to that
anywhere in the world to champagne soil
and and of course those vineyards are
home to some of the uk's best um best
vintages
so um yeah so some some some great
alternatives there to fry i think i know
why that is claire i think i'm right in
saying that that soil and rock formation
goes underneath the channel and it's the
same one that is in champagne goes under
the channel and then pops up again uh
where this night timber vineyard is i
think i
i don't know that's somewhere at the
back of my mind from somewhere if i'm
wrong i'm sorry nobody write to me and
tell me otherwise um
are you more of a staycation person or
do you still think it's worth trying to
get out through these airports and ports
at the moment you know we are
an overcrowded little island is nice to
get away but it's just so difficult
yeah i mean a bit of both actually i had
a really amazing weekend uh last weekend
at the cotswolds at the falcon state um
but for this fall our summer holiday we
are actually i mean people think we are
mad but we're going to monsoon rajasthan
uh because my friends at scott dunn have
assured me it is actually a really
brilliant time to go
and do temple see the taj and
go on a secret tiger safari so
we are taking advantage of off-season to
india and
much much cheaper flights
okay and the secret is there are no
tigers we must leave it there claire
thanks very much
indeed us on the program this morning
thanks a lot lots of fantastic tips
there from claire irvin travel advisor
adventurer and writer of course uh
coming up going to be joined by the
aegis education secretary and liz trust
supporter that's james cleverley as the
final two in the tory leadership race
continue to make their case we've been
hearing from jeremy hunt at this hour
who is supporting rishi sunak and
confessed on tv that he almost ran me
over with his bicycle it's an actual
true fact
[Music]